is there anything that's exciting you
down the road that could work that could
start to solve this that we could get
excited about
oh god the last the list is so long i
mean i honestly think some of the most
exciting stuff is stuff that i can see
each of us adopting in our lives as
opposed to these kind of
far out of reach no offense i don't have
a lot of say over that steel production
facility
in my own daily life so like utilities
letting me
check a box and say that i want 100 of
my electricity to come from zero carbon
resources
like i check a box i forget about it the
next month and i have done
something meaningful that is measurable
like it sounds so boring but that me
that's exciting and you know what not
not even everywhere in this country but
certainly not around the world that's
not just a default option you can pick
what i'll say is in this whole
transition i know julio you've got lots
of great thoughts about tech
we have an opportunity to either
exacerbate equity gaps make them worse
or narrow them and really intentional
steps forward can narrow them we know
where a power plan is the lucky thing
about it is they don't have feet and
they don't run around you know we know
where it's going to be
we know the community that will be
impacted we know the makeup of that
community
like we can do things very intentionally
we won't do that if we don't think about
it
um but julio you you have the rundown on
the cool tech so i'm going to pitch it
over to you
there's two things that i'm super
excited about uh and i'm gonna start
with with the most obvious and nearest
term one which is hydrogen
uh hydrogen is gonna be a big honking
thing
and the nice thing about hydrogen is
there's no pollution with it
none when you consume hydrogen it turns
into water and that's it it either makes
heat or it makes electricity and either
way the byproducts water
okay so if you make the hydrogen with a
low carbon footprint
you can do a lot and and it's the swiss
army knife of decarbonization it goes
into heavy industry it goes into the
transportation sector
you can make fuels out of it like
methanol or ammonia
you can put it straight into the grid
there's all kinds of stuff you can do
and in that in the context of that i
want to
head back to something melissa just
mentioned um
if you replace an existing
power plant of some kind with a hydrogen
plant
you should have no pollution with it of
any kind
so you should be able to do that in a
way that's fair and equitable and to do
that requires union labor
so you should be able to do it in a way
which is good paying jobs that are
long-term jobs right so so there's a way
in which hydrogen can be brought forward
that's smart and equitable and real
and we'll see if we do that or not dr
freeman why isn't that happening now is
because the technology is too new or
just existing
just the resistance change in general
there's a couple of reasons but
uh first and foremost there is
there's no market aligned policy it goes
back to where i started right
so we have a production tax credit for
solar and wind we have an investment tax
credit for solar and when we got nothing
for hydrogen
so who's going to make it to make zero
carbon hydrogen today cost between two
times and ten times more
than hydrogen that emits who's going to
make it
we need to create market aligning
incentives to do it and that could be a
clean energy standard a clean
electricity standard
that could be a production tax credit
for low carbon hydrogen
there's all kinds of things you could do
but but you got to start getting the
market apparatus going
okay you also need to do things like
replace truck engines with fuel cells
it'll take some time it'll take some
money to do that you need to have
fueling stations where people can get
hydrogen so
there's i could spend the whole rest of
this program talking about that i won't
there's
good reasons why not but but that's
something i'm excited about because the
technology's gotten cheap enough
and the ambition's gotten high enough
that we're starting to get alignment
between the ambition and the price
and that's that's when exciting stuff
starts to happen
and at this point i just hope that the
crazy people on both ends of the
dumbbell don't shrink it away
um because in fact there's a lot of
heavy lifting could be done in the
middle and it looks like we're getting
to that point
the other thing i'm excited about is co2
removal
so we have that residual emission stack
that we can't get rid of
okay and for the past 20 years i've been
hearing people say don't even talk about
that because if we talk about it we'll
we'll stop reducing emissions well guess
what like we didn't reduce emissions
we're stuffed we still need to do this
people didn't want to talk about carbon
capture because it would give people an
excuse to keep admitting
harbor carbon excuse me that's like
saying the existence of diet coke means
nobody will lose weight it's a
ridiculous argument but
you know there you go but but uh be that
as it may
uh we if now we have we
realize that we are going to overshoot
if we want to have a justin verdin world
we're going to have to do a lot of co2
removal to get to zero
again to melissa's point net zero is
clarifying zero means nothing so if you
make anything anywhere
you have to remove that amount and
when you get into big scale co2 removal
we need trees we need soils we need
direct air capture devices which i
am excited about we need biohydrogen
with ccs
we need carbon mineralization we need
mangroves
we need all of the above on that too
there's just not enough tonnage
with any one of those things you can't
get the 10 billion tons a year we're
going to need
with just one thing so it's all of the
above all over again
and it gives us i think an opportunity
to be generous with each other again to
say we know we need to spend money
we know we need to try lots of stuff we
know
one of us alone is not going to do the
job
so let's all work together and do this
incredibly important thing
and we've seen mark carney at the bank
of england now launched this
transparency thing for carbon offsets
we've seen a bunch of banks start
getting into this we've seen
tech companies like google and amazon
and microsoft and apple start getting
into the co2 removal business
that's exciting so this is a very
non-scientist question or maybe possibly
not even questions there's technology up
there where
let's call a device or something sucks
carbon out of the air like how does that
work where can it go like i'm just more
curious of the implementation of
that technology that's probably that
technology was invented in the 30s for
submarines like we've had it for a long
time
what's exciting now is we're starting to
scale it so there's a handful of
companies companies like climb works and
carbon engineering
that will do that which will build the
plant and suck the co2 out of the air
and store it in the deep geosphere
forever
good so we didn't have companies 10
years ago now we got companies that's a
step forward
and right now the technology is ballpark
four to six hundred bucks a ton which is
too much to pay
great we know how to reduce costs that's
one thing we do know how to do
you put money into innovation you make
market aligning policies you deploy a
bunch of stuff and the costs go down
like we've done that with everything for
leds for batteries for flat screen tvs
like we know the recipe for that one and
now we're starting to see
voluntary markets come together and
companies like microsoft
put money into it and companies like
carbon direct organizing their thinking
and companies like mckinsey recommending
to governments that they change the way
they think
like that's like you're starting to see
bits of the ecosystem come together in a
useful way
and you can put that anywhere in the
world you can put it in the north slope
of alaska
you can put it in the gulf of mexico you
can put it in abu dhabi you need zero
carbon heat
you need zero carbon electricity as long
as you got those things
you can do direct air capture in the new
york context
believe it or not the building codes can
help
because there's a new civic code that
says all
buildings have to be net zero by 2025.
which is very very challenging and if
they don't
they have to pay 477 a ton
that's enough money to start paying for
stuff and that is where look governments
can't create value but they can they can
align incentives they can incentivize
value right
and that's kind of where we need to go
david what is exciting you
i want to talk about culture right i
think what excites me is
i think what julio mentioned of like
people start to
are starting to see the art of the
possible and clean energy and that
really excites me and i think
um what julia mentioned of like you know
10 years ago solar was 10 times more
expensive
you know wind was three times more
expensive right and when you
when you like see that on a scientist
projection well you're like well
okay maybe we'll see right when that's
backward looking
that's a big deal right and i think
people start to get
excited about what the world can look
like not what it looks like today i
think
you know we've been we've been spoiled
by moore's law in the technology world
that
you know things just get smaller and
cheaper over time when it comes to
semiconductors
what people have shown is that like the
same process of like
you double the scale you reduce costs
like that doesn't just apply to
semiconductors
right and i think what part of the we
just have to start
and i think there's so many people now
getting in this game and getting excited
about it
that it peop you know big companies are
listening governments are listening
things are starting to change is it
happening fast enough no
but i think part of that is our
opportunity right for those that are in
the space
to be in it and to hopefully do really
well from it i would
say too you know i think uh your point
around short change being a four-letter
word
i think when it's imposed no matter who
it is it's a four-letter
word right when you feel like you have a
control of your own world and control of
your own change and can benefit from
that change
it's the most exciting thing in the
world and i would point to
what california's done with low carbon
fuel standard you know and
like the growth and renewable energy
credits that have happened as a result
of
for farmers that have pig farms and cow
farms like
you go up and down iowa wisconsin
illinois indiana
there's not a cow farm in a pig farm
that hasn't been knocked on their door
like 20 times
because it is a gold rush right now and
those guys are making a ton of money
on basically taking the farts from their
cows
their their cows and their pigs and
doing something with it and then selling
that gas
into the california market that the that
the big companies over there have to pay
for
like they are making a ton of money you
got a lot of farmers in the midwest who
made a ton of money
from wind and solar like that change is
exciting right that's why you get
i think really positive change in those
communities when it's imposed it's
negative
right and this i think clean energy is a
way for entrepreneurs to benefit
one thing you recommend the average
human to start doing that if everybody
was doing we'd be in a better place
i i think what julia said resonated with
me like learn first care second
learn what in your community in your
business
in your you know day-to-day life you can
how you can
impact and some of it you know for some
people it's just going to be electing
the right people calling your senator
your
you know we live in a representative
democracy we have the ability to change
what happens in policy but for a lot of
people like their business can make
change right and
and i think what we talked about with
efficiency like putting leds is a cost
benefit thing like it there's a huge
amount of benefits not just mentioned
energy efficiency like
it it generates more light makes life it
makes world it's safer
right it makes it look better for your
customers so like
simple stuff right done in aggregate i
think can change the world
and i think that as people start to
learn and then care
um i really like that as a framework dr
lott what would you say
i mean i think it stems off what david
just said which is realizing like this
is your health we're talking about and
this is your health right now we're
talking about this is important
this matters right now this isn't some
mystical thing in the future and so
you know we've got so many layers of
government that we can say hey you
represent
me this is important to me and we need
to act on this
and with our collective voices we can do
a lot like that's how policy gets done
is when we say okay across aisles across
conversations like we want this this is
important to us
let's do it so people get so consumed
with dc and dc is important
but so is your local city hall right
probably more important i agree with you
um and dr freeman
close with you the short snippy answer
if there's one thing people can do they
can vote
please go god damn vote vote god damn it
we need p we need voters vote about this
stop voting we got issues but i'm with
you
like we're still at 40 voting like
perhaps we can do a little better than
that
you know but but really the the most
important thing for people to do right
now more than anything else
like i'm i still like learn and care
like that's a good thing to do
learn that 77 of americans don't have
rooftops so they can't do rooftop solar
like that's a good thing to learn
before you care about how to fix that um
but but the thing that i
want people to do more than anything
else like be
generous and the person i'm channeling
these days more than anybody else is
yoda
i'm really trying to channel yoda in
everything i do these days
and my favorite yoda quote is fear leads
to anger
anger leads to hate and hate leads to
suffering
that's no way to fix this problem folks
we can't fix it by being more
angry and more shrill we got to be
generous and work together to fix the
problems
and if we listen and if we're generous
we can get there
[Music]
you